so we've been talking quite a bit over
the last four years but in particular in
the period leading up to the election
and then since the election when we've
seen
not 75 million people as some
in the house of representatives have
been claiming today but certainly
tens of millions of people fall for the
false belief
that the 2020 presidential election was
somehow
stolen from donald trump even though
donald trump was the rightful winner
it's
disheartening and concerning and scary
that so many people have fallen for that
and in thinking about how that came to
be um
the idea of a shared psychosis is
important to
think about and there's a very
interesting article in scientific
american
which we're going to link to on our
youtube channel which summarizes
some of dr bandy xle's views
on what moved donald trump's followers
to fall collectively for these delusions
and to then also become violent and
behave destructively as we saw
on january 6 during the trump riot in
washington dc
and um the the uh answers are widespread
and there are many overlaps between what
dr
lee says who's been a guest on this
program by the way
uh and what we talked about uh about
magical thinking
several weeks ago and when bandy lee was
asked in this interview in scientific
america
american what attracts people to trump
dr lee says that there are two
major emotional drives there's
narcissistic
symbiosis and then there's the idea of
shared psychosis now
narcissistic symbiosis we've sort of
talked about before
and that is described as the
developmental
wounds that make the leader follower
relationship
attractive to both the leader trump
is hungry for people to worship him
essentially because he lacks self-worth
and we know this to be true we know
about trump's relationship with his
father
and how uh you know the the relationship
between fred trump and donald trump is
not that different
than the relationship we observe between
trump and his children in particular don
jr who seems also desperate
for his father's adulation when trump
doesn't really seem to care that much
uh about his children at least in the
sort of traditional ways as we've seen
publicly um that we understand that
that's that's something that
uh we've we've identified um uh
relatively early
shared psychosis is very interesting
because what we are essentially talking
about is
a national level delusion that is
plaguing
tens of millions of people again not 75
million not all 75 million trump voters
are are part of this
but certainly we would look at the polls
and you know when 60 percent of trump
voters believed up until weeks ago
that it is trump who would be
inaugurated in a week not joe biden
it certainly afflicts many of them and
that
is as again referred to by dr bandy lee
the infectiousness of symptoms that go
beyond
group psychology we've talked for a long
time about
how did those tea party people end up
supporting in 2010
candidates who were running on policies
that weren't good for them
running on low taxes for the rich which
these people were never going to be rich
we understand the group psychology
aspect pretty well
jonathan height who i've interviewed has
talked about that we understand that
the uh um when we talk about shared
psychosis as dr
bandy lee refers to it the process is
you put in an influential position
somebody who is afflicted by this
psychosis now
we don't have to guess does trump
believe the delusions or does he repeat
them
even though he doesn't believe them it
doesn't matter the point is
he repeats them and he's in a position
of power and
then you can see it spread
through the population through either an
emotional bond
that trump's followers believe they have
with him or
the heightening of people already
predisposed to conspiratorial thinking
or paranoia or people with a propensity
for violence and that
fully describes the people that ended up
violently storming the capital last week
so let's go through again
all of the different elements that exist
here
you start with a group of followers of
trump that on average is more
predisposed to violence we know that
we know that uh and we know that from
looking at the
um brain differences essentially between
reactionary right wingers and other
groups we know that there's more of a
predisposition to violence there there's
more paranoia
there's more fear there's more belief
that other people are out to get you and
on and on and on so you start with that
group
now many of those people even though
they hold those beliefs they're not
going to fall for the shared psychosis
they're not going to believe the
delusions
and they are not actually going to go to
the capitol and commit violent acts
but then you take that group that larger
group that just is
slightly more predisposed to violence
more predisposed to conspiratorial and
paranoid thinking
and then you do a two-month campaign
where the leader
the narcissistic leader repeats repeats
repeats these delusions about it was
stolen
and there were massive dumps of votes
and
uh this happened in pennsylvania and in
michigan the watchers weren't allowed to
see and then in georgia this right you
repeat it repeat it you do two months
to that group and you're going to take
some sub section of those
who are going to be infected for lack of
a better term by these ideas that are
being spread by trump of the theft of
the election
and then you get to january 6th where
you have
a group broadly speaking more
predisposed to conspiratorial thinking
uh and also more predisposed to violence
not all of them willing to do it in real
life and for two months you hammer
hammer hammer on them and then you start
using terms like
we've got to fight and you literally say
we're going to go down
to pennsylvania down pennsylvania avenue
to the capitol
and that's how you get what we got last
week and
the the psychology of it is very
interesting i do think that
you know there are some who might just
write this off and say well okay yeah i
mean
you're sort of uh psychologizing
in some way um what
may or may not be an accurate
psychoanalysis
but i think it can't be written off
because if we don't understand it we're
gonna have a very difficult time dealing
with it and by the way merely
understanding it doesn't actually tell
us how to deal with it
but uh you know we talked about this a
few
a month ago or so where you know we i i
explained
that to understand why they are willing
to do these things you have to
understand that a lot of these trump
supporters believe that they are at war
they're at war against the left and the
media and scientists atheists communist
marxists
the democrats who stole the election and
on and on
and in a sense they idealize violence as
well it's not just that they're
predisposed to it
they idealize violence as being implicit
as implying that they are also
courageous they're willing to take the
risk of going to the capitol and being
violent
and uh when you are at war a normal way
of
interacting with the world evaporates
and you justify
what you're doing much like you we see
militaries justify what
absent a theater of war would be
completely absurd
immoral behavior lying is obviously
valid if you're at war
lying is no big deal and what we saw on
january 6 was that
even property destruction violence
storming the capital
insurrection etc um even that is
justified when you have this belief
that you're at war and you share the
psychosis with the great leader so
there's a lot there and i encourage you
to check out the
the article and what you very quickly
realize is that
there are self-reinforcing aspects of
this that make it very difficult to
break people out of it
very very important thing to understand